hey guys it's max today we're taking
another look at the brand new 13-inch
razor blade stealth now not only is this
thin it's light three pounds it's
slightly thinner than the MacBook Pro I
like how it looks a trackpad is quite
nice the best in any razor a laptop but
we also have a quad-core CPU which is
awesome that we can have a quad-core in
such a small laptop now but the biggest
unique feature is that it has a
dedicated graphics card so we have the
MX 154 gigabytes of memory and this is
the 25 watt version so in a previous
video I unbox this I looked at all the
features all the updates did some
benchmarks and then compared it to a
13-inch MacBook Pro now a lot of people
that want to have an ultra light thin
laptop now we have quad cores but the
biggest downside is most of them don't
have dedicated graphics cards so when
you start you doing some tasks like
productivity or gaming video editing it
just kind of falls apart because of that
so that's where this thing comes into
play and today we're gonna look at the
gaming aspect and see how it performs in
Fortnite black ops 4 and what I'm most
excited about and that is battlefield 5
and see what kind of frame rates we can
get and what settings we can pull off
now I do have a link to the exact model
that I am testing in the video
description below if you guys want to go
and check that out and also have some
other links like the gaming mouse that I
am using as well so let's get into it so
it looks like four-night gave us 720p
rendering at medium quality overall so
huh not very impressive let's turn on
our frame rate counter here alrighty so
looks like we're sitting right around 60
frames per second I have vertical sync
off but I must still somehow beyond
because we're pinned here at 60 not
going above right off the bat I have to
say the graphics suck 720p at medium
settings no not very good but we'll see
if we'll be able to make that better ok
I don't want to play at 720p because
this displays 1080p so let's set that to
1080p
and the graphics definitely look a lot
better and frame rates looking like 50s
49 52 58 it's jumping all over the place
but can I please kill him
so since I'm so terrible at this let's
just follow this guy around for a little
bit it looks like we're in the mid 50's
and it's pretty consistent here and
since we're running at 1080p on such a
small display 13-inch display the
graphics look pretty decent let me see
if I can go in here and I'll change
everything to hi
I got motion blur off alrighty now we're
sitting out 44 41 35 yeah this is too
low because as soon as you get into any
type of a fight if you're dipping down
that low you know you're not gonna get
very smooth results alright so now we're
in our 30s 33 32 40 33 I personally
don't like to play that low I know a lot
of console gamers do and the graphics
definitely look nicer but I personally
would not run at the settings I would
keep it at medium so MX 150 the 25 watt
version with Fortnight we're looking at
roughly 1080p medium settings and then
you're looking at mid 50s so pretty
decent experience all right now for
something much more my style we have
black ops sports go into the settings
and see what was decided for us
interestingly refresh rate at 30 Hertz
hmm I don't like that so let's change
that back 1920 by 1080 so 1080p that's
good I render resolution at 66 so is
that like somewhere between 1080p and 7
2014 height to hit black ops four saying
hey don't want to play with in 1080p
with this laptop so that's not good so
let's see what we get this doesn't
really inspire much confidence so we're
at 47 40
six here and it's just not very fluid I
don't know what's going on it just
doesn't it doesn't feel right the frame
rates aren't that bad I mean their load
but they're not you know lower than
consoles are but something with the
screen tearing I don't know if it's
drivers or the game or something else
going on that just does not feel good I
know something just feels off about it
does not feel normal it doesn't feel
good almost feels like slow motion or
something I don't know maybe it's just
the fact that the graphics are turned
down so low and I'm not used to that so
to be honest I am a little bit
disappointed I was expecting better
results than this
looking at the OpenCL results and of
course those don't have to correlate
obviously they don't but I was expecting
a little bit better performance than
this playing at 1080p at low and very
low settings and we're in the 30 frames
per second and it's like almost like I'm
constantly getting a little bit of some
kind of a glitching or slow motion which
could be due to some other issues but I
don't think this video is gonna be very
long like some other ones I've done just
because this is not an enjoyable
experience at all I guess I should just
go throw it into a 720p like it was kind
of recommending and see what happens
all right so for a final test I switched
over 720p and everything looks terrible
in the menu see I can barely read the
names I mean look at this I can barely
read the text lettuce right there it is
what it is I mean both black ops and
fortnight set it to 720 rendering and
Wow the graphics look terrible aliasing
everywhere now framerate is in the 70s
60s 90 70 so the frame rates a lot
better and yeah this is definitely a
smoother experience naik actually feel
like and I can actually game even though
it looks terrible
but at least I'm not getting some slo-mo
stuttery
playback
alright alright alright alright alright
alright I come on where are ya so what
I've just realized is that a lot of
people are going to be mislead now I
should have known better and I knew it
wasn't gonna be that good of a gaming
machine but being from Razer and being
dedicated graphics you would think that
it performed semi decently now if the
laptop cost this much and once again I
have a link in the video description to
it it should be better be able to play
better than 720p honestly you should be
able to play at low settings at 1080p
and have a decent experience and that is
just not the case
with this laptop here if you're gonna be
getting an external graphics card you
know what's the point of getting the
model will GPU can spend less money hmm
but if you want to get the higher RAM
and the higher kind of configs you are
gonna be buying that better built-in
graphics card now there's still kind of
some hope if you are going to be using
this for say video editing and if you
haven't checked out my other channel I
will link in the video description so
I'll be testing it out how it does with
4k video editing because that's one area
where we don't have a lot of options
something small and light now with the
new Intel CPUs that are quad core and
having a dedicated graphics card and
with OpenCL scores that we are getting I
am expecting to have some pretty good
video editing performance compared to
just say like a MacBook with integrated
graphics all right so now on to what I
wanted to do that is battlefield 5 and
unfortunately I am having no luck at all
the game will not launch on this laptop
it says I need to upgrade my drivers and
I've tried three separate drivers and
they all say they won't upgrade with
this version of Windows and I just
updated windows and no other updates are
showing up so I don't know what in the
world is going on it is very late I have
been at work other than some breaks for
13 hours today yeah so
let's just say I am kind of done with
this laptop I'll give you guys my
overall opinions I think that this
laptop is not a good gaming laptop
unfortunately I think a lot of people
are gonna be fooled by having that
dedicated graphics card because I mean
it is dedicated that's at 4 gigabytes of
RAM and when you actually go and start
gaming just base off of the kind of the
benchmarks that we saw and both black
ops and Fortnight they give you 720p and
playing 720p for something that's this
expensive is very unfortunate and if you
guys saw our PC bill that we did I'll
put a little card up here if your guys
are disappointed by the footage in this
video guys go check that out that thing
actually performed really well a PC
under $500 way better than than what
this thing is performing like so if
you're somebody is actually interested
in gaming I would highly highly
recommend not getting this version here
going for the 15-inch model I know it's
heavier I know it's larger but it's the
same price and that is gonna give you a
10 60 max Q graphics card that's gonna
perform way way way better than this now
like I said I still have some hope for
it for those you guys want to do some
productivity say photo editing or what's
more in my side of kind of the world is
video editing I will be testing this out
on my other channel I will have a link
in the video description but man playing
back at 1080p low and very low in black
ops 4 that is quite disappointing this
is the max with max tech very tired I'm
gonna be heading home right now thank
you guys for sticking around this long
and I'll see you in the next video